[Music]
did you ever imagine I ever imagined
that this is this was gonna be like your
idle experience like definitely not like
we were all I remember like being in the
room with everybody and then telling us
okay guys we gotta fire home like
coronavirus just not safe for us to be
here anymore
and like all of us like our jaws just
dropped and they were like like we had
no idea we're gonna be sent home I mean
above all us you know that you're gonna
be part of an historic season yeah it
was hard for every one day you know
settle in me like oh my goodness we're
not like with each other but I think
once everyone looked past that we were
like this is so cool and we're gonna be
didn't go down to history for us
you sound so great and it's incredible
you're growing during a quarantine you
somehow have figured out how to continue
to grow as a start what was it like for
you doing that first audition in front
of the judges like auditioning for in
front of Lionel Richie
but it's wild to me and then getting and
then getting that feedback that you got
that like such positive feedback as much
as I want a critique I just think he
just did a great job I was like nervous
to be in front of them but I wasn't
nervous to you know sing don't
control how to lick
oh I felt like I couldn't breathe that
guy go in oh my goodness like they're
just like staring at me while I sing I
was like it's just like look at the
floor I mean I like freaked out too much
I was like trying not to like fangirl
over them Lauren I think you have such a
god-given gift you may be 16 but that
voice is a thousand years old
I gotta say you've been knocking it out
of the park just just killing it and to
know to be like this girl is from Canada
and to be able to say that has been such
a cool thing what's the response been
for you yeah just the response from
everybody has just been crazy support um
like people just from like all over
Canada are like the Canadian girl oh my
goodness she's from Canada and like
everyone's been so supportive I've had
so many positive comments and you know
tweets like everything everyone's just
been so kind